meine noch mal eng ich war hier paolo
drogenboss von mexiko oder sonstwas 300
einheiten
das ist rashid mehrfach stürmte die
polizei schwer bewaffnet seine shisha
bar die polizei rechtfertigt die
regelmäßigen razzien auch mit
selbstgemachten zahlen der clan
statistik diesen zahlen der polizei
würde ich nicht trauen würde ich mal
hinterfragen instrumentalisieren polizei
und politik statistiken zur sogenannten
klaren kriminalität ein polizei insider
wird in diesem film behaupten die klaren
statistik wird mit banalen einträgen
aufgelöst hat er wertet für uns geheime
polizei dokumente aus die diese sicht
belegen werden und die frage aufwerfen
kleinkriminalität tricks die polizei ein
spektakulärer raub mitten in berlin
morde auf offener straße sek ist die
shisha bars stürmen auf der suche nach
waffen drogen schwarz-gelb
gangsta-rapper die aus angst vor einem
clan nur unter polizeischutz leben
können wie hier bushido das sind die
bilder die bundesweit furore machen
zugegeben auch wir medien frontal21 und
das zdf lieben die systeme
der bezirk ist eine hochburg krimineller
arabischer kleids die shisha bars gelten
als wohnzimmer der clans hier also
sollen viele plant ihr unwesen treiben
berlin neukölln besonders im fokus
shisha bars und sie machen auch dadurch
andere cafés entkoppelt viele betroffene
fühlen sich zu unrecht kriminalisiert
müsse ihn gehe sie betreibt eine shisha
bar in neukölln
ich habe hier arbeiter spitze halt meine
von meinen arbeitern krankenkassen
spezielle alles wir machen alles 1 2
achtmal ihr könnt ja controlling
komplett aber die sollen ja nicht mit so
einer horde kommen und mit zehn
mannschaft sondern kommt mit
maschinengewehr zahl reicht vollkommen
aus wenn hier zehn mannschaftswagen vor
der tür stehen und reinlaufen als ob
hier jemand jemand umgebracht hat da
denke ich mir wo bin ich jetzt gelandet
manche kunden die sind einfach ängstlich
die kriegen angst dadurch es sind auch
welche die nicht mehr herkommen die
polizei rechtfertigt ihr vorgehen mit
steigender kriminalität so genannter
clans nicht nur in berlin
schwerpunktregionen sind niedersachsen
nrw bremen allein in berlin führte die
polizei 2009 10 382 razzien durch
durchschnittlich mehr als eine pro tag
noch mehr waren es in nordrhein
westfalen innenminister schmücken sich
gerne mit dem anziehen
hier herrscht das recht des staates und
da die das offensichtlich so nicht
verstehen muss man ihnen das amt zurzeit
ich einen gang höher zu schalten und das
werden wir die will einen starken staat
und das zeigen wir können gerne über
klanggewaltig sprechen aber dazu gehört
auch die polizeiarbeit mohammed angie
reed ist journalist berichtet auch über
kriminelle strukturen er findet aber
dass zu unkritisch mit den
veröffentlichten zahlen der polizei
umgegangen wird wenn man die
berichterstattung sich anschaut zur
kleinkriminalität dann findet man immer
ganz fehlen wenn sich die
berichterstattungen anschaut so
kritischer betrachtung von polizei
arbeitern für ein wandteil weniger im
herbst 2009 10 meldet sich ein
polizeibeamter bei ihm
er möchte anonym bleiben die clans
statistik wird mit banalen einträgen
aufgeplustert der polizist arbeitet in
niedersachsen möchte auspacken er
berichtet amjahid wie die polizei
trickst
denn ein 15-jähriger junge zb die schule
schwänzt und in einem kiosk in hannover
aus langeweile ein schokoriegel cloud
landet er weil er nach namen aus der
clan tabelle trägt automatisch in der
cloud statistik der polizist gibt an
amjahid interne dokumente weiter daraus
geht hervor dass tatverdächtige ohne
klaren bezug in die klauen statistik
einfließen zum beispiel dieser
verdächtige er entspricht er nicht dem
klassischen profil eines
kleinkriminellen amjahid wird noch
weitere brisante details in den
dokumenten finden shisha bar betreiber
müssen damit leben dass ihr geschäft als
hotspot für kleinkriminelle gilt das ist
nennt sie hat als kellnerin lange in
einer shisha bar gearbeitet und razzien
miterlebt
man fühlt sich einfach nur krass
stigmatisiert in eine schublade gesteckt
kriminalisiert und überhaupt nicht so
als ob irgendjemand etwas für uns als
bürger machen möchte malley liebt 0 köln
sie lebt gerne in ihren bezirken doch
das image von neukölln und den shisha
bars hat sich durch die vielen razzien
und den medientrubel massiv verändert
also ich vertraue der polizei in der
politik überhaupt nicht mehr und so geht
es auch vielen betroffenen von den rat
zählen wir stoßen auch viel frustration
und enttäuschung warum macht die polizei
dass er trägt politisch dafür
verantworten
berlins innensenator andreas geisel wir
zeigen ihnen die aufnahmen von mary und
den anderen betroffenen nicht unsere
absicht normale gewerbetreibenden die
sich an die regeln halten
in dieser art und weise bestätigen dass
es nicht das ziel aber das kann nicht
bedeuten dass wir nicht gegen kriminelle
strukturen vorgehen doch bleibt dabei
weiter machen wie bisher
ich bilde mir nicht ein dass wir
kriminalität auf diese art und weise
abschaffen aber ich bilde mir schon dass
der staat zeigen kann dass er gewillt
ist seine regeln durchzusetzen
was auffällig ist es wird granatenmäßig
dazu
es wirkt unverhältnismäßig es wirkt so
als wäre es politisch motiviert und
juristische motiviert hannes honecker
ist jurist die vielen razzien und die
sogenannte politik der nadelstiche sieht
er kritisch
ich meine dass die nadelstiche
jedenfalls dann rechtswidrig sind wenn
sie keine ausreichende verdachts
grundlage haben und das ganze politische
gefahren also das ganze was dazu erklärt
wird deutet an dass es in erster linie
darum geht symbolpolitik zu betreiben
ein schwerer vorwurf führt die polizei
fast täglich razzien durch weil es in
politiker innen so gut aussehen lässt
auch in den medien
ich als journalist bin dann immer
interessiert was ist bei solarzellen
rausgekommen
und wenn es heißt da ist überhaupt
nichts rausbekommen dann frage ich mich
warum diese razzia in eine gewisse
statistik verlangt zahlen machen politik
naja und manchmal macht politik auch
zahlen wie dieses dokument des
niedersächsischen polizei in siders
zeigt insgesamt wurden 2017 in der
polizei software data warehouse 1408
datensätze erfasst
das problem ein falscher nachname reicht
um in der lka clan statistik zu landen
stellen wir uns vor das würde mit diesem
sehr bekannten namen passieren wenn die
polizei in einem bundesland sagt alle
müllers sind kriminell
dann reicht es schon diesen nachnamen zu
tragen und die datenbank sorgt dafür
wenn man einen von diesen namen eintippt
egal was es für einen kontext ist dass
dieser fall automatisch in die klauen
statistik liest und lässt das gesamte
gehalt das gilt sogar bei
unterschiedlichen schreibweisen ein
beispiel der name mir davon gibt es
unterschiedliche schreibweisen jede
variante schafft es in die klauen
statistik so sind es gleich vier fälle
mehr
das grundproblem ist überhaupt über
diese familiennamen zu gehen das führt
auch dazu dass leute die sich überhaupt
gar nicht kennen plötzlich in einem clan
landen weil irgendjemand bei den
sicherheitsbehörden gesagt hat die haben
ähnliche nachnamen oder denselben
deswegen gehören die in einem clan
strukturen soll so die statistik
künstlich aufgebläht werden
das fragen wir das landeskriminalamt in
niedersachsen das antwortet das gelegte
polizei dokument sei nur für den
dienstgebrauch eingestuft deshalb könne
die behörde auf unsere frage nicht
konkret eingehen das lka betont es wolle
kriminellen clan strukturen konsequent
mit allen zur verfügung stehenden
rechtsstaatlichen mitteln begegnen
doch daran glauben nicht mal alle
polizisten kaum einer möchte über die
diskriminierende fahndungs praxis
sprechen
wir haben einen gefunden in bremen
thomas müller hat vier jahre in der
abteilung der organisierten kriminalität
ermittelt
heute ist er pensioniert und kann offen
sprechen wenn man menschen in einem
polizeilichen daten system erfasst muss
man grund haben und der name kann kein
grund sein und damit ist das ganze für
mich ganz einfach das ist einfach
schlicht einfach schlicht und einfach
vermuten
der polizist müller wirft der polizei
vor verfassungswidrig zu handeln und
glaubt deren zahl nicht diesen zahlen
der der polizei würde ich nicht trauen
die würde ich immer mal hinterfragen
durch eine wissenschaftliche studie zum
beispiel das wäre auch mal nicht viele
maßnahmen für den begriff klaren
kriminalität gibt es bis heute keine
feste definition dennoch wird er von der
polizei gerne benutzt die shisha bar
besitzer in neukölln ärgert dass man
redet von also dieses wort benutzt sich
sehr um den klaren kriminalität steigt
nicht was plan bedeutet es gibt es
entweder man ist kriminell wenn man es
nicht kriminell
natürlich ist es so dass straftaten
begangen werden und welchen zusätzlichen
aufklärungs betracht liefert die
benennung dass es sich um clans handelt
honecker hat einen schweren verdacht die
polizei instrumentalisiert den begriff
clan für ihre eigenen zwecke
ein funktionär der sachmittel und der
personal mittel akquirieren will benutzt
ihn aber möglicherweise weil er ängste
weckt weil er effekte auslöst wohin
diese effekte im schlimmsten fall führen
können das hat der terroranschlag in
hanau gezeigt ein rechts terrorist
ermordeten menschen vor und in zwei
shisha bars das attentat zeige wie
gefährlich die zuschreibung von
kriminalität auf bestimmte
bevölkerungsgruppen sei nachdem
mannschaft von hanau muss man ja noch
mal ganz anders darüber nachdenken was
eigentlich bedeutet des shisha bars
existenz schon als besondere orte
gebrandmarkt werden
die ethnisierung von kriminalität führt
auch zu einem komischen
gesellschaftlichen klima dass sehr viele
minderheiten in sehr konkret in gefahr
bringt glaube ich halte das für sehr
weit hergeholt wir die polizei gehandelt
nicht rassistisch die polizei geht gegen
kriminalität vor und das muss sie tun
berlin
christian gisy rashid und sie fühlen
sich in ihrer lebenswelt bedroht und
wünschen sich mehr fairness von der
zivilgesellschaft auch von den medien
dafür sammelt eine berliner initiative
unterschriften gegen die razzien das
motto kein generalverdacht hast du
erfahrung mit diskriminierender
polizeiarbeit gemacht schreibt es uns in
die kommentare